في اوروبا ايضا تلوح في الافق مؤشرات
ايجابيه من شان تخفيف وطاه ازمه ثياب
الطاقه التي ضربت القاره منذ اشهر فبعد
معاناته الحقيقيه عاشتها العديد من
البلدان الاوروبيه على خلفيه ايقاف
امدادات الغاز الروسيه يبدو ان قدره
افتراض الغاز المسال ستزداد خلال هذا
العام فمن المتوقع ان ترتفع قدره الاستراد
بنسبه 20% بحلول ديسمبر المقبل وذلك وفق
معلومات رصدتها منصه
ميديا المختصه في الطاقه هذا ونجحت اوروبا
في تنويع مصادر امداداتها من الغاز كما تم
التخطيط لبناء محطات استيراد جديده افتتحت
واحده منها مؤخرا في المانيا
ويبدو ان ازمه الغاز تجاوزت مراحلها
الصعبه حيث انخفض سعر الجمله للغاز
الطبيعي في اوروبا بنور 50% في غضون شهر
واحد وهو ادنى مستوى له منذ بدايه الحرب
في اوكرانيا ويرجع سبب هذا لانخفاض الى
دفء فصل الشتاء نسبيا في اوروبا هذه السنه
ما سمح بتوفير المخزون